bảo cảm mọi nhất được công bố, ra các ta đã chính thức vật Tokyo để trở thành siêu đô thị đông dần nhất thế giới với gần 40.000 người.
Thành phố công lồ của Indonesia tiếp tục phình tò, giò tất lộ đô thị hoàn yang nhập tư mạnh và tình trạng dịch chuyển láo đồng về khu đủ thủ đô.
Đà ca của bỏ la đẻ s đứng thứ 2 vài khoảng 40.000 cho giân trong khi Tokyo tưởng dẫn đầu như thật kì, giời sụ thứ 3, với 3,5.000 người.
Indonesia hiện cũng là cua ra đông dần thứ 2 thế giới với 2 trong tạng mới sảo trưởng người. Cho tình trạng thủ đô ra các ta thường xuyên của ta ấy.
Tắc ngẽn khiến thị thải hơn 5,7 gần thế về bay mọi năm.
chính phủ đáng xây dự thủ đô mới nụ xanh tò ra chỉ ra 3,5.000 người.
Rồi kiến hoàn thành của 5,5.000 người của trong thầm mi tảm. Nằm chia sẻ gánh nặng hả tần và giảm vử dụng cho thành phố ra các ta.
Cúc trong bảo gạo chuyển bọc đô thị hoa hai nghi của trong thầm mi lâm.
Các đô thị hiện chiếm phủ mới lâm phần trăm trong tổng số tạng khai hai tị gián tròn cầu.
Tăng mạnh sôi mức hai người phần trăm của 5,7 gần. Nói sổ siêu đô thị trên thế giới đã tăng gốc bún lần kể từ 5,7 gần.
Nói sổ thị trăm với 5,7 gần. Nói sổ đô thị bảo 5,7 gần.
Nói sổ đô thị bảo 5,7 gần. Nói sổ đô thị bảo 5,7 gần.